first feature is a pretty big deal
especially with something like this so I
was wondering when you were thinking
about what to take after conversations
with friends what were some of your top
priorities so you pick something that
like one would help you evolve your
craft but also continue to show this
industry what you're capable of thank
you um I don't know I mean like like I
was just kind of auditioning and this
came through and I was just like oh my
God this is like you know just the
script in itself was just astonishing to
read like it's such a you know as much
as the film takes you on a right
watching it the script is the same like
it I was you know just gasping and like
I just it's a visal reaction to the
script but I was so excited to audition
and I think you know it's always really
exciting getting to play a character
that really you know makes you step out
of your comfort zone and um and where
you don't feel like yourself or you get
to kind of explore lots of different
things and this was definitely one of
them so I just felt so lucky that I got
to to do that um after after
conversations so was great I love how
different they are like anytime I could
see back-to-back projects where like you
see this massive range sign me up for
that very curious with a film like this
what did Emerald ask you to audition
with what particular scene you know what
it was actually the
scene the finish's final scene in the
bath that was
serly and which was honestly I was so
excited because I think but that's one
of the best pieces of writing I've ever
read h i mean that yeah that piece of
writing just kind of blew my mind so um
it was obviously both kind of terrifying
and all so I was just so excited to get
to work on it so um yeah so I went that
and then I I think I may have done also
like the first uh scene which just uh
Venicia and um Oliver when they're
outside um yeah I think I think that was
that oh we're coming back to the bathtub
conversation because I need to put up a
spoiler warning at the end so we could
talk about that a little more in depth
first though so you audition you sign on
to be in the film at that point what
would you say are your biggest burning
questions for emerald in terms of you
know who venisha is and how her family
operates yeah I mean I guess this is
like a world that not too familiar with
myself and stuff so Emerald was like my
reference for everything you know I
think I I asked her everything and um
and learned so much from her as a
director like she's
incredibly precise and she knows exactly
the kind of film that she wants to make
but then she also allows for just so
much kind of fun and you know
improvisation as well and stuff and uh
but yeah I mean I pretty much kind of
asked her everything I think and um
and you know I think the characters all
have their own kind of I guess
personal vulnerabilities and arcs and I
think what's really fascinating is I
think an audience member with this films
you're kind of seeing it Through The
Eyes of Oliver of learning who these
people are and what their kind of um
yeah vulnerabilities are and also um how
to kind of get under their skin and so
it was really exciting to to play with
her because I think she's someone who
definitely presents a certain way but
actually is quite different so yeah
those qualities make this a an
especially satisfying movie to watch
over and over I saw it for the second
time last night and now that I could
track everything through it's like a
really rich full experience yeah it's
weird I had the same thing when I read
the script again at the first time I was
like God I'm so naive I really it coming
for so
long I'm glad I'm I'm in good company so
uh not that this movie really needs this
kind of information but when I get
obsessed with the movie I become a
backstory nerd and I want to know
everything about everybody so is there
anything you had to come up with for her
that we don't necessarily see on screen
or hear about via dialogue but we can
still feel informing your performance
throughout the movie I think what I
always used to think about fenicia is
like what what does she do when you know
Felix and Farley aren't there like she
just lives in that house all year round
and like you know I think she probably
goes to London on the weekends for
parties or events or whatever but I
think she's she's in a kind of almost
old-fashioned traditional way like lives
in this in this home and kind of waits
for I suppose Felix to come and bring
people and um and then she kind of comes
alive but but so I I thought a lot about
what what she does and actually I think
she's quite a bored person I think she's
quite bored with you know I guess she
has a lot in a material sense um but I
think is probably feeling like she's
lacking in terms of uh a lot of maybe
emotional needs she's a very lonely
person I think um so I think I just yeah
spend quite a bit of time being like
what does she
do when she's not you know in her kind
of element and and kind of getting to
entertain people who come to the house
so
that was kind of some yeah do you know
what her favorite movie is if not if not
super bad maybe she picked super bad
maybe super bad I don't know what her
that's something now
us just be like what about her bedroom
like did you ever talk about what that
might look like and what little detail
she would have because it does it does
feel like almost every single room has
you know not necessarily a cold feeling
but like a less personal feeling than
the traditional bedroom would have yes
it probably would have that feeling but
then just filled with like so much
clothes and so much makeup and
accessories and posters and like CDs and
magazines and you know I think her you
know her mom was a model and I think she
probably um you know took lots of her
kind of clothes and old bathing suits
and like that probably has just the most
incredible
wardrobe um yeah that's probably how I
see it probably quite pink and black
maybe all right good combo there I would
believe all of that all right to get
into the cast now and some of your scene
Partners can you pinpoint a Time on set
when a scene partner did just what you
needed them to do in a moment where it
helped you reach something in your
character that you wouldn't have been
able to access without them wow oh my
god
um oh that's a really good question I
mean I not to go back to the scene a lot
but I think is the bathtub scene yeah
there's just so you could talk about it
freely I'll just do this right here and
now at this point I'll put the spoiler
warning up for our viewers so if they
haven't seen salurn you want to push
pause go see the movie then you come
back to the video and it starts right
here okay btub scene have at it not even
like I guess it was just you know like
acting with Barry is one of the most
exciting things in the world because you
just don't like he is so
um he's so unpredictable in that amazing
way of like everything is so in the
moment and so instinctual and Primal and
like
um yeah and I think with that scene it's
obviously very kind of head-to-head and
it's all cards on the table and I think
there's a kind of sinister line I think
he's walking of not exposing himself
entirely but he's you know and I think
um I think the writing does so much for
that seen anyway but I think just the
way that he was looking at me and
responding to what I was saying I found
really drove me along and um but I think
yeah I mean all of all of the actors in
This film are just incredible and like
you know like I really like being in a
scene with rosmond you really didn't
have to do that much like she's I've
never I've never seen anything like it
and so I think a lot of the uh scenes I
had to do very much felt like I just had
to yeah like anything like react because
people were just bringing the most
incredible things and uh yeah I think I
could I I wouldn't have done anything if
it wasn't for them I guess truly an
example of a perfectly cast film and
also to go back to the bathtub monologue
that that is like Pitch Perfect and
expertly delivered monologue probably
one of my favorite dialogue heavy scenes
of of the year I'm not just saying that
cuz we're talking it really is something
else kind of a big question when
preparing for a scene like that and I
don't know if you think about it this
specifically but what is the first thing
you do to start preparing for something
like that like step one that puts you on
the right track but then also what's the
last piece of that puzzle the thing that
falls into place that makes you say to
yourself I'm ready to get on set and
nail it now I really don't know like I
think you never know I guess how
anything's going to go and you you try
and put your best foot forward but I I
suppose because I audition with that
scene I was very familiar with it from
the offset and just loved working on it
and so um I
think I think just I found just really
like leaning into the language and also
I think for her she is finally revealing
all of the things that she can see right
through and um and so I
think yeah I guess just just letting
letting the words do it and and
responding to Barry and um and also I
think there can be a thing sometimes you
can do where you're like oh today is
that scene and I think I find that quite
challenging because you're like you can
put too much pressure on things um so
yeah so I I tried to just you know just
go oh this is the the Great Piece of
writing that I love so I just go so good
this this again might the answer might
be no and it might be too hyper Pacific
specific but is there any particular
beat of that monologue that you found
most challenging to calibrate
emotionally because what that basically
is one big emotional roller coaster
where she hits so many different
phases um like challenge what I guess
in I think probably I don't even know if
it's necessarily a challenge but just
the bit that made me feel most like oh
is just when they kiss I just stuff it
is just the worst kiss in the world such
a loaded beat too there's just so like
it's not like before there's so much
more to unpack there now reallyy Grim so
yeah so maybe that but all right here's
a broader question that I wanted you to
be able to answer freely but again you
brought it up too I know Emerald likes
to be very collaborative on set so of
all the scenes you filmed which one
would you say changed the most from
script to screen where you found
something unexpected and special in the
moment I think I remember I was in the
other room but I remember um when they
when the everyone first meets Oliver um
and everyone's in the kind of uh sitting
room and he can hear them talking about
him outside the door I think Emerald
just really let the guys run with that
and um I remember that just being lots
of takes of like what's going to come
out now and being in the other room and
just laughing my head off like that but
I think to be honest I think all of the
kind of um group ones like the the
breakfasts or the dinners or whatever
and where everyone's kind of listening
or everyone's kind of involved like
Emerald will sometimes just let it go
and see what comes um and yeah I mean
like everyone's just total Pros so I was
just having a great time what is
something you appreciate about Emerald
as an act director that helped you here
and you hope to see more directors you
work with in the future well I think
she's someone who I mean she's like one
of the smartest people I've ever ever
met and she knows exactly the kind of um
films that she want wants to make but
she's you know obviously coming from
characters perspectives as well and is
sensitive to um yeah obviously to to
acting and and um the difficulties of
that as well well
and I guess she's someone that really is
with you every step of the way and is so
kind of approachable and available all
of the time um and creates such a like
playful warm um collaborative
environment where everyone feels
included and um you know and also I
think just just speaking to Emerald
generally
like she has this like insane film
archive in her head like she an an an an
literary archive and um she kind of has
she's one of those people that kind of
has a reference for everything and um
and I think what she does so amazingly
in her films like she you know I think
she did it in promising young woman and
with this is like her kind of
understanding of genre and how you know
she'll kind of present you with a
certain kind of genre that you
recognize and then start with that and
then be able to totally flip it on its
head and use that tool to kind of then
do her own thing with it so she's just
so skilled and extraordinary and um but
also is like you know your friend and is
really just there with you and having
the crack with you so um so yeah so
she's I just couldn't speak higher of
her she's a genre bending Master but I
also want to see her do a full-fledged
horror movie so badly so she's her yeah
her her understanding of horror is like
she's yeah she's
incredible she's incredible as Are you
seriously congratulations on this I love
your work I'm rooting for you I can't
wait to see what you do next you so
much